salut à tous bonnes années 2020 j'espère
que vous allez bien que vous avez passé
de bonnes fêtes et aujourd'hui on va
parler essentiellement d'organisation de
programmes et de ce qui va se passer
dans les prochains mois sur cette chaîne
alors on va rentrer tout de suite dans
le vif du sujet c'est un sujet que
j'avais déjà abordé un petit peu sur le
bazar du grenier dans une vidéo
explicative où je parraine la vidéo des
dix ans donc je vais le répéter ici pour
les gens qui ne suivraient pas le bazar
du grenier mais vous avez tort il ya
plein de choses super laser du grenier
de réactifs fait la pub c'est pas du
tout ce qui était prévu que donc si ce
qui s'était passé
souvenez vous la vidéo des dix ans cet
automne la fusion de tous les univers
mais en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est
que on n'a pas réussi à gagner
suffisamment de temps sur les vidéos
comment je voulais en fait à la base on
s'était dit que pendant les mois qui
suivent l été 2010 9 on allait faire des
petites vidéos pour gagner du temps pour
avoir le temps de produire la vidéo des
dix ans sauf qu'en fait il est aperçu
il s'est passé un truc qu'on avait
oublié depuis depuis quelques années
c'est que on ne peut pas descendre sous
les 3 semaines de fabrication pour un
épisode jdg ça n'est pas possible même
en compressant tout même en en faisant
l'écriture super rapidement même en
faisant les grands tournants super
rapidement bref sous les 3 semaines
c'est pas possible en fait ce qui s'est
passé donc c'est que c'est l'épisode
dragon's lair je crois même en rechange
de fabrication on a peut-être gagné
trois jours sur le mois et en trois
jours tu produis pas une vidéo si
colossal que la vidéo des dix ans en
trois jours donc c'est pas possible
du coup il ya quelque chose de clair qui
est apparu c'est que pour produire cette
vidéo il fallait faire sauter des vidéos
or le problème c'est vous le savez sur
youtube les mois de la fin d'année c'est
à dire de octobre à décembre en gros ce
sont les gros mois de la publicité c'est
moi qui rapporte le plus
donc c'était un peu débile de notre part
de se dire on va faire sauter les mois
qui rapporte le plus pur
pour sortir la vidéo des dix ans en fin
d'année donc c'était con donc on s'est
plutôt dit bon écoute on va faire on va
continuer notre programme normal et on
s'attellera à la vidéo dédiée à la
rentrée donc à partir du mois de janvier
là où le mois de janvier février c'est
des mois qui rapporte que dalle pour
nous donc on peut se permettre de faire
sauter des vidéos pour se concentrer sur
sur la grosse vidéo de dix ans du coup
on est le mois de janvier
et là on entre réellement maintenant
dans la phase de pré prod de la vidéo
des dix ans ce qui veut dire que pour la
première fois en dix ans je dis beaucoup
de fois dix ans dans cette vidéo
pour la première fois depuis dix ans on
va faire sauter des vidéos c'est à dire
qu'il va y avoir des mois où il y aura
pas d'épisode jdg parce qu'on va
réellement se concentrer à l'écriture à
l'organisation c'est plein de choses
j'ai noté ça sur un papier c'est là en
gros pour vous expliquer la pré prod
c'est quoi ça comprend tous cas avant
avant le tournage
donc là actuellement on a commencé on
est rentré il ya quelques jours le 10 6
on a commencé l'écriture donc on en est
à peu près aux serres de l'écriture de
la première version de l'écriture mais
on va faire une première version qui on
va repasser dessus pour ajouter des gags
une deuxième version puis ensuite on va
se tord et bordé la vidéo qui on va
réfléchir au lieu de tournage on va
chercher des lieux de tournage aura
recruté une équipe on va chercher des
figurants on va chercher du matos on va
donc c'est tout ce qui se passe avant la
production de la vidéo donc en gros ça
ça va nous prendre
alors je dis des peut-être parce qu'en
fait je sais pas combien de temps ça va
nous prendre mais en gros on s'accorde
un mois pour l'écriture un mois pour
l'organisation puisque il va aussi
falloir fabriquer les costumes et les
gros costume qu'il faut fabriquer il ya
plein de choses à organiser
donc je vais pas vous donner de date je
vais vous dire la vidéo des dix ans elle
sera telle date
dans ma tête j'ai envie que ça sorte
quelque part entre mars et avril
mais en réalité j'en sais rien moi mon
avis en mars on sera en train de tourner
après il y aura peut-être un mois un
mois entier de montage et de poses
propre ce cas plein d'effets spéciaux à
faire je peux pas vous donner de date et
vous dire à telle date ça va sortir tout
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que du
coup le programme de ceux de ce début
d'année 2020 va être énormément
chamboulé il va y avoir des vidéos qui
vont sûrement sauter par exemple je
pense qu'au mois de janvier il y aura
juste pas de vidéo jdg je pense
peut-être que ensuite dans le mois de
février
pendant que nous on sera en train de
d'organiser en mode alors chercher le
tournage organiser les figurants
chercher le préparer les fonds verts
machin bref tout ça il y aura peut-être
une autre vidéo qui va sortir peu mais
j'en sais rien vraiment je ne sais pas
du tout si on a le temps on ont
peut-être on fera on mettra on essaiera
de glisser un petit jdg un petit papy
gré des gens j'en sais rien je sais pas
où justin hors sujet mais on essaiera de
lui c'est quelque chose si on peut mais
en tout cas voilà tout ça pour vous dire
que la priorité pour nous pour ce début
d'année 2020 c'est réellement la vidéo
des dix ans où on va mettre énormément
de temps à la produire peut-être trois
ou quatre fois plus de temps qu'une
vidéo normal parce qu'on veut vraiment
en prendre soin je dis pas que je
garantis diffusera de la merde jean
saret mais en tout cas on veut mettre
des et plus d'efforts que dedans que
d'habitude
donc c'est pour ça que ça implique des
vidéos qui vont sauter donc c'est si on
fait si je fais cette vidéo c'est pour
vous informer voilà juste que il va y
avoir donc plusieurs vidéos qui vont
sauter donc ne vous inquiétez pas c'est
juste pour vous dire ça en fait ce
message des vidéos y aura pas de vidéo
dans l'intervalle une peut-être si on a
le temps mais c'est pas sûr ça fait une
vidéo pour rien dire en fait une
rencontre
tout ça pour dire aussi on a d'autres
trucs qui vont aurait pas ce que je
regarde le papier qui avaient épié de
trucs qui vont arriver sur le bazar on a
des idées pour le bazar on n'a pas
encore vraiment les réfléchi à comment
les faire on a des super idée vraiment
super cool j'ai pas envie de vous payer
vos envies qu'on me pique mes idées j'ai
pas envie qu'on nous pique les idées
qu'on a mais c'est vraiment vraiment
cool
c'est ce truc on ya réfléchi avec cb
karim est vraiment ça peut être super
cool donc n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
sur le bazar poursuivre puisque de toute
façon le programme du bazar va pas
changer lui le bazar ça va plus ou moins
continué donc n'hésitez pas à nous
suivre sur le bazar cie à d'autres
annonces à faire comme ça de ce type
pour vous tenir informé d'autres retards
ou de je sais pas de ce qu'est ce qui
pourrait arriver ce sera plutôt sur le
bazar là je le fais vraiment
exceptionnellement sur la chaîne
principale pour les gens qui ne suivent
pas le bazar
ben voila mais sur ce on se voit
peut-être bientôt ou peut-être pas
j'espère que vous avez apprécié c'est
super info en attendant à bien bonne
continuation et puis on se voit dans
quelques mois pour la grosse vidéo et en
attendant j'espère qu'on pourra vous
donner
quelque chose à manger entre temps sinon
n'oubliez pas il ya le hasard du grenier
salut à tous ce show
[Musique]